hello I'm Diane Worth I'm professor of
immunology and infectious disease at the
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
and today I'm talking with Dan Hartmann
of the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
Dan welcome
well thanks Dianne it's a pleasure to be
here as director of integrated
development what does that mean in the
context of malaria eradication versus
product development so in product
development we are constantly thinking
about how to pull all of the different
pieces together whether it's a clinical
plan a regulatory strategy a
manufacturing plan a toxicology plan
thinking about the sequence of these
various activities and how to do that in
the most efficient cost-effective way as
I look at all of the research being done
in malaria they tend to be one-off you
know we're gonna answer this question
and then we're going to answer the other
question and then the subsequent
question and you have a whole bunch of
questions being answered but how do you
integrate all of those different results
into a cost effective way to eradicate
malaria how do you think about the
combination of various vector control
tools do I need bed nets and IRS and you
know newer vector control tools or can I
substitute in how do you think about
that well if I have an effective vector
control do I need to do mass Drug
Administration and and what type of
population and in what type of setting
you know high intensity low intensity
indoor outdoor there's so many different
covariates and in so many pieces of
information that I think this is a great
opportunity to do model-based Global
Health and try to say what type of an
environment am i entering what type of
information do I have and what is the
most cost effective way to utilize the
tools
as opposed to just being add-on therapy
it's when Bill and Melinda Gates in 2007
announced their goal to eradicate
malaria I was in the room and I remember
thinking now this is it's too hard the
biology you know the transmission is you
know one case leads to a hundred and and
then as I thought about it I realized it
was a paradigm shift right that now you
had to think not about a disease but
actually eradicating a biological
organism and that's a very different
thing and I think that paradigm shift
you see reflected now in the research
and the implementation we are now
focusing much less on disease clearly
disease is important but we're
proceeding much less on disease than we
are on how do we get rid of the organism
and it's transmission as I've been
working with a team and we fund a fair
amount of research the the one question
that we always ask is how will this help
us eradicate malaria and and it's been
interesting to think through that in the
grants that we make and and how we're
approaching all of our work as opposed
to you know thinking like a physician
like I am - okay I see a patient I treat
a patient you've talked a bit about
evaluating the the current tools in
terms of will they contribute to
eradication but where do you see the
holes in the toolbox where or where are
the missing tools is I've been looking
at and trying to evaluate the current
toolbox one of the things that I would
love to see us develop is something that
is less reliant on human behavior
because I think human behavior is so
difficult to change and you know if we
look at at polio there is a human
behavior required for the eradication of
polio you have human behavior on the
part of the vaccinators they have to go
out they have to find everybody on the
planet
the places that they're challenged most
near their their endgame as areas with
social strife and in malaria because of
the vector there may be opportunities to
think about a tool that doesn't require
one human being interacting with another
or one human being taking a medication
for a given period of time
and we know adherence even in the best
situations is challenging you know what
if we could alter the vector with
minimal human behavior
it's an interesting idea you know it
gives the opportunity to think in a
completely different way not focus at
all on the parasite but focus on the
vector I think other things that we're
looking to do is to reduce the reliance
on continuous medication for P vivax can
we go from a 14-day regimen to a single
dose the single dose would be I think
beneficial in multiple different ways
both for treatment because the most
common regimen is a bi be three days in
a row what if you could do that in a
single day you know what would happen to
resistance because you would be you know
getting a full dose and in a single day
as well as thinking about mass Drug
Administration if that's a tool that
would help us eradicate malaria it's a
lot easier to do mass drug
administration if you're giving a single
dose then maybe you have to come back
multiple times so again I think that
also relates to taking the human
behavior factor out of it good in fact
one of the challenges as we talked about
products whether it's genetically
engineering mosquitoes or it's new drugs
or vaccines one of the big issues is the
regulatory issues how do you take things
from discovery and get them approved
particularly in situations where it's a
new idea it's not something
that the industry has done before or or
rarely does and I know that you think
about this a lot and I'm wondering what
your perspective is what the approach
will be one of the things that we try to
do and and are doing more frequently
today is integrated development of which
integrated development includes what is
your regulatory strategy and it's really
hard to plan if you don't know what your
end is going to look like so early
interactions with regulators talking to
them about new products what could these
products be what could the endpoints be
and then developing a strategy on how to
get there in in the most effective way
again remembering that most products
fail so you if you don't know where
you're going and you don't know what the
steps are gonna get there if you do fail
you're likely to fail late as opposed to
failing early which is a very expensive
endeavor being able to make a clear case
as to why you think a product would be
safe and effective or have an
appropriate risk benefit in a given
situation is obviously necessary and
then having the the open discussions
with various regulatory agencies and
sometimes I see us thinking more
developed world regulatory agencies but
what we really need to do is to go to
the communities that we work and get
their perspectives on a risk benefit
mm-hmm I think that's a very important
point you know because it is a different
population that's going to uptake almost
everything that's developed during this
phase of the elimination eradication
campaign
I had a fascinating discussion with one
of my colleagues from Senegal and he was
telling me about malaria in the 1990s
and he was the you know one of the chief
physicians at this hospital and Senegal
and chloroquine resistance hit their
area and he says you know I would sign
2250
certificates a day and I don't have that
experience and a lot of regularly
regulators in developed world don't have
that experience so when you start
thinking about risk and benefit unless
you have that perspective and you've
lived in those communities it's really
hard to have that so that's one of the
things that we're starting to do
especially with novel products is really
get out into the communities where
they're going to be used in and get
their perspectives early on and and try
to have you know whether it's W Joe
stringent regulatory agencies from
developed worlds national regulatory
agencies from countries where it will be
utilized eventually I'll have that
discussion together we've made some
really good progress in that area we've
been working on a project called African
regulatory medicine harmonization which
is thinking taking a regional approach
as to a country approach for product
introduction because most of the
countries don't have a very
well-developed regulatory agency there
are a few but for the most part in
Africa in particular other than South
Africa I think there's relatively little
local expertise in country but from a
regional perspective that could be of
interest we're trying to do multiple
things with this approach so one is to
get a critical mass as you were
describing so we can take the east
african community pull their resources
and their and their best people together
and have them do like dossier reviews
that that's a positive thing the way
works we've have it set up right now is
we're bringing in other regulators like
whether it's swiss medic or folks from
whu-oh or other stringent regulatory
agencies to help answer questions that
they might have and they're also relying
on other stringent regulatory agency
reviews so instead of starting from
scratch they're looking at somebody
else's report ideally and saying okay do
i agree with this report as opposed to
having
through through an entire dossier and
the whole purpose of that is to make
sure you have a quality review and make
sure it's timely but it also benefits
manufacturers I was a manufacturer and
like in my old role and I wanted to
submit a drug to sub-saharan Africa I
would have over 50 dossiers that I would
have to prepare and submit and get
questions back from 50 countries respond
to all 54 a market with very marginal
turn on that well we can create a system
where we have four or five regional
areas and you can drop in four or five
dossiers as opposed to 50 get back four
or five sets of questions and have a
general format that everybody's agreed
to that would dramatically reduce the
the burden on the manufacturers we did a
study about three years ago looking at
the time it takes for a product to go
through the entire regulatory system and
get to people in developing countries in
developed countries it's about 9 to 12
months in developing countries
especially in sub-saharan sub-saharan
Africa we found it's about four to seven
years and it's usually approved in the
developed world goes to whu-oh for
pre-qualification then it goes to the
national regulatory agencies for their
review and approval frequently that none
of those three groups were taking
advantage of prior reviews so they were
doing de novo review each toc de novo
review each time and that obviously
lengthened it by 3x just if you did that
and in in the ideal situation the other
thing that we found is manufacturers
because they had to apply to each
country this the spread of their
submissions of dossiers was sometimes up
to four years right because it had to
fit into their workflow exactly what
we're trying to do through this
harmonization effort
to support mutual reliance and and
minimize I would say non-value-added
activity of applying to each different
country as opposed to regions and we've
had some some great success in East
Africa and and now this approach in this
harmonization effort is moving into West
Africa South Africa already had started
something on their own yet WH o
pre-qualification we found that the drug
side was relying on stringent regulatory
agency reviews but the vaccine side
wasn't and there was about a 13 month
difference in a review time between drug
and vaccines that was a relatively easy
change to do and and and now the
timelines are much better looking at
mutual reliance of national regulatory
agencies on either WH o or other
stringent regulatory agencies reports is
again streamlined it single dossiers as
opposed to multiple so all of these
things have reduced the overall
timelines by close to fifty percent to
what they were three years ago and it
also strikes me that there is an
enormous capacity building potential
here because as as this develops perhaps
the Africans will even be able to do
standalone approval at the highest level
because at some point perhaps that's the
right strategy for registering a product
that's going to be either primarily or
only used in a in a malaria endemic
country I think that really is where we
want to go and the regional approach
makes a sentence to try to stand up 50
plus you know high-quality regulatory
agencies even within the next decade I
think would be almost impossible exactly
and also not productive because malaria
is going to have to be solved on a
regional level you know the disease
doesn't no borders that's something
that's becoming accept
as a as a mode of interaction between
countries what advice would you give to
people early in their career or even pre
career what kinds of things do you think
are important for people to think about
that's a great question I I think that
as scientists and physician scientists
we underestimate the importance of
leadership training I went through 15
years of post high school education and
99% of it was science-based the
leadership component is a totally
different component and and I think it's
one that can be learned for the last
almost 20 years I read some type of
leadership book every quarter I take
time out of my busy schedule to take
some type of course that I think will
help my career development whether it's
you know I've taken courses on
implementation management change
management decision quality a variety of
leadership courses it has really helped
my career and helped me understand what
good leadership looks like and and and
how I can constantly improve myself
I think career development has to start
with the individual nobody is going to
develop your career for you
the sooner I realize that then I could
start taking control over my own career
development understand what some of my
areas of weakness were how am I going to
fix those and and develop that has made
a significant difference in in terms of
how I think how I work early on in my
career I think it was less important but
but today most of what I try to do is
influence my environment mm-hmm and and
certainly I try to do that through
scientific you know discussions and
arguments if you will but a lot of it is
is I think some of the softer skills
whether it's an emotional intelligence
component
or you know how do you think about
decision quality which is something that
we tend to overlook we think we all make
great decisions but you can actually
tell that did you have a quality process
in your decision-making at the time you
make the decision irrespective of
outcome interesting advice because I
agree we we don't spend a lot of time
teaching people how to lead or or
systematically how to make decisions we
know how to test a scientific hypothesis
or follow a protocol but but we don't we
don't focus on how do you get to
decisions and how do you lead people to
decisions well thank you very much it
was a wonder wonderful that you could
spend time with our students thank you